TOM BROXTON: Hello.
Good morning.
Good afternoon, rather.
This is Josh Sassoon.
JOSH SASSOON: This
is Tom Broxton.
TOM BROXTON: And we're
designers on the user
experience team at YouTube, and
we wanted to talk to you
today a bit about how we
design products in a
multi-screen world.
We wanted to give you a bit of a
kind of a factory tour and a
peek behind the curtain of some
of the ways that we do
things at YouTube and some of
the reasons behind some of the
changes that you'll be seeing on
YouTube in the future, and
then what some of those
might look like.
We'd give you a little
sneak peek of that.
So with that, I'll hand you over
to Josh, and he can begin
by telling you a little
bit about YouTube.
JOSH SASSOON: So just to take a
big picture view of YouTube,
YouTube is actually a
really, really tough
problem to design for.
And when you think about
YouTube, it's probably just,
up to a lot of people, a place
where you go for cat videos.
But when you think about
YouTube as a corpus of
content, it's a huge
unstructured, massive corpus
with a huge breadth
of content--
everything from cat videos
to revolutions--
and it really doesn't have
a consistent structure.
YouTube is kind of this "Choose
Your Own Adventure"
experience.
And it's important to or step
back from YouTube and
understand what YouTube
is and what it isn't.
And YouTube really isn't like
any other service out there.
Nothing like it exists.
YouTube is essentially
the container for the
entire world of video.
Everything is on YouTube.
Everything on YouTube is
uploaded, and it can be
virtually anything.
And on top of that, our
audience is everyone--
everyone across the world
and every demographic.
Everyone watches YouTube.
And what's great about YouTube
is it's unique in its ability
to provide for this incredible
universal experience.
And it can also be an
incredibly personal
experience.
It's both of those things, so
we have to really find a
balance between that.
We have to find a way to show
everyone in the world "Gangnam
Style." And on the more personal
level, I personally
am learning how to play the
violin off of a series of
YouTube videos from a creator
in a completely different
state, and it's very
personal to me.
And that's a very different
experience than the universal.
So the beauty of YouTube is
that there is this shared
experience that's universal, and
it's very collaborative.
I think most everyone's heard
of the "Harlem Shake" meme
that came up recently, where
not only did it start on
YouTube, but it was actually
because of YouTube that
everyone was able to collaborate
and create these
videos and parody and mimic
each others' videos and
actually create something that
wasn't there because of
YouTube as a platform.
And then on the more personal
level, there's this really
intimate, social aspect to
YouTube, where people have
YouTube parties.
They crowd around a phone or a
laptop, and everyone's dying
to share a video with
one another.
So we have this incredible
challenge of balancing, again,
the universal and the personal
and anything that can be a
completely global phenomenon to
something that's very much
social and intimate that's just
your group of friends.
And the end experience of
YouTube is incredibly hard to
describe because of that.
So most people will say that
YouTube is overwhelming, that
they can't really capture it
or describe in any way.
It doesn't have enough structure
or anything that's
consistent enough about the
corpus of content to really
capture in any way.
And there's this common feeling
amongst our viewers
that it's hard to decide what
to watch next or how to
discover something new or
how to find something
that they'll love.
And on top of that, it's even
harder for them to refind it
or to collect it in a way where
they know how to keep
track of it.
And so the general sentiment
is, I know that YouTube has
everything on it.
I just don't know how
to make sense of it.
And that's what makes it such a
tough problem to design for.
TOM BROXTON: And so as YouTube
keeps growing and our
relationship with online video
grows and changes, and what
online video is grows and
changes, we're really moving
from being this web-based site
to being a service running
across a multiplicity
of devices.
So we begin to think about
YouTube as a platform upon
which we can share content out
the world, to people wherever
they are and whatever
they're looking at.
So at the moment, we feel that
we've got a series of apps,
each specialized on their own
platform, that tries to take
the best aspect of that platform
and allow you to get
to the content in the way that
that platform makes sense.
But the problem with this is
that it gives the impression
to our viewers that something
you found or bookmarked or
saved in one place isn't
available in another place.
And it doesn't give a great
sense of one service and one
set of videos that you're
looking on across the world.
So as we work on our next
generation of product design,
we're really thinking about how
can we harmonize that so
we can move away from this sort
of web first, and these
other devices second, to a
service that's at the center
of everything with thousands
of devices and thousands of
products that are pointing into
this, so you can connect
to the content you want at the
right time in whatever way
suits you best.
And as designers, we really want
to provide this in a way
that's delightful and enjoyable
to everyone, to make
that connection experience
exciting.
Because from cat videos to
revolutions, people tell us
about these amazing and
inspiring experiences that
they have on YouTube.
And we really see our job as
connecting those people
together and making it really
easy for those kind of
connections and experiences
to happen.
So at Google, at YouTube, we
really believe that the way to
do this, the way to achieve
great design that is relevant
to people is to really
understand the people,
understand the user and their
needs and what they're trying
to get out of things.
So the problem with that is, as
Josh has already said, the
breadth of our audience is
such that many of the
traditional methods that I
learned for understanding the
audience that are coming to your
site or to your service
are quite ineffective.
So one of the great tools we
have to address this at
YouTube, or one of the great
assets we have to address this
at YouTube, is a strong research
team who can really
come up with some innovative
ways of addressing the user
needs, understanding user needs,
and finding ways to
address them.
So they come up with some really
innovative methods,
especially for attacking this
problem of how things change
as we move to a more
device-centric world.
They've come up with some really
innovative ways to
tackle this.
And I wanted to share some of
those with you, because I
think they're really
interesting, and then some of
the high-level insights that
we're taking away from those
and what we're learning about
why people use our service the
way they do.
So just to explain
how this works.
They've been running a series
of large-scale diary studies
when they send out these
booklets to volunteers, and
people record and share daily
activities about how video
consumption fits into
their life.
There's a variety of exercises
in the books--
day-by-day diaries and these
time wheels that I'll explain
a little bit more in a moment.
And the overall effect was
that they gave us some
insights into what people are
doing during the day.
So this is the time wheel
diagram I was just describing,
and the idea of this is that
people can record and give us
insight into how their day
works, what devices they're
using to consume media and
video during the day.
So here, the little markers
show where they are, what
they're doing.
So you can see transport, on I'm
at home, or I'm at work,
and who they're with as well, so
we get an understanding of
kind of social activity.
And then the inside purple ring
is phone activity, and
you can see the short
phone interactions.
And then we've got
a tablet wheel.
The laptop is the yellow, and
TV is the long sessions that
you see on the outside.
And then, we can take many,
many, many of these diagrams,
and we can use many clever and
also not so clever methods of
processing them and looking at
patterns and try to get these
patterns and understand the
behaviors and motivations as
to why people pick up a
particular device and use it
in a particular way and
what they're trying
to get out of it.
And then, we can check those
against the actual traffic
patterns that we see
coming to our site.
And we can see how these things
match up, and there's a
lot of information you can
draw from that kind of
comparison.
So to begin to get to some of
the insights that we're
drawing out of these--
that's just one method.
There are quite a lot of other
pieces that we're using.
So we try to draw all these
together into some insights
that I could share
with you today.
And the most basic starting
ones are just some device
principles that as designers we
like to get down to a sort
of framework or a set of ideas
that we can all agree on so
that when we talk about phone
or tablet with each other as
we develop products, we'll have
a sort of basic, shared
understanding of how
these things work.
So I want to share that with
you quickly to begin with,
because it underpins a lot
of what's following.
So I'll just go through them
quickly, device by device.
The phone is sort of typified by
this pattern you see in the
purple there of really morning
til evening, like I wake up
til I go to bed.
It's always with me, and it's
these fast, frequent
interactions.
You know how it is.
You're always checking
your phone.
You're almost like a chicken
pecking at the corn.
But what we do notice is that
a lot of this interaction is
reactionary.
So people are really getting
status notifications or
updates, or people are telling
them about something.
So phone-based interactions are
what we're thinking of as
reactionary.
And the other thing we really
notice about the phone--
and people talk about it
in interviews-- is
how personal it is.
People are very unwilling
to let their phone go.
So you've got a strong chance
that the person on the end of
that device is the person
you think it is.
The only exception really to
this personality or the
personal nature of the phone
is in child pacification,
where we constantly see.
And these are people who'll just
hand over any device to
get some peace.
So that's the one person
who might be on the
other end of the phone.
And another surprise for us was
just that although people
often use the term phone and
mobile interchangeably, we're
trying to stop doing that,
because there's less mobile
usage on the phone then
you'd expect.
I was expecting a lot of it to
be kind of on the bus or
traveling, and a lot of mobile
usage is actually at home.
More than half of the usage
we're seeing is
from within the home.
So the tablet, to kind of
contrast that, it seems to
have a slightly surrogate role
in people's lives, and the
usage is slightly unclear.
People often talk about using
it instead of some other
device, so instead of my phone
or instead of my laptop or
something like that.
The marked difference from the
phone is that usage seems to
be planned much more.
People talk about downloading a
movie to watch later to take
on the bus, on the train, or I
want to read a book in bed.
So it tends to be more
ritualistic and less habitual.
And so that's leading us to
the conclusion that using
scaled up phone UIs on
the tablet is not
always the best idea.
The reason people could
be using it
could be slightly different.
And the surprising thing is
people don't seem be using
them-- at least for video--
people don't seem to be using
them as much as they
think they do.
If you ask them in an interview,
they'll say, oh, I
always use my tablet.
I love my tablet.
And then when you look at the
patterns through the day, the
tablet usage is much lower than
they suggest themselves.
The PC, just quickly,
is to perceived much
more as a work device.
Usage is much more
in the daytime.
This is especially true with
the arrival of the tablet.
People, as I said, instead of,
people are switching much more
of their usage towards
the tablet.
And the other interesting
point we noticed--
even though we think so much
about living in a kind of
post-desktop world,
post-keyboard world, there are
still so many organizational
tasks that people can't
achieve through these
other interfaces.
People still talk about turning
back to their laptop
as a control panel and as
a device to, in the end,
organize things and
complex tasks.
And finally, the TV is still
sort of the epicenter of video
consumption.
Everything else seems to
revolve around the TV.
Sessions are longer,
less interactive.
You see these big orange bars.
And they're pretty constant.
Through all of the research
that we're doing, we see
people have it on in
the background.
It's often associated
with multitasking.
You'll see the phone or the
tablet, all these things being
used at the same time.
And our important takeaway for
the TV is really that it's a
shared device or it's
a social device.
People are very aware that there
are many people looking
at the screen at
the same time.
So be careful about what you
put up on the TV and are
sharing, since through
social data, people
don't appreciate that.
There's a couple of interesting
trends or sort of
continuums that we notice that
run across all the devices in
the order that I showed them.
So as you go from a small screen
size to a large screen
size, session length
and the length of
videos viewed increases.
It's kind of intuitively
sensible, right?
You're more likely to watch
a movie on the TV.
But also, interactions
go down.
So people want to interact
less with a screen that's
bigger and further away.
And whereas phone is a habitual
device-- the way
we're describing is phone is
habitual device, and the TV is
a ritualistic device.
People have times of day when
they want to go to their TV,
but as I said, they kind of pick
up and use the phone all
through the day.
And again, it seems to kind of
spread according to the screen
size across all of
the devices.
And the personal
issue as well.
Phone is a very personal device,
and TV is seen as a
very social device, and tablet
somewhere in the middle.
I'm sort of happy to share my
tablet in the way that I'm not
happy to share my phone.
So the second insight that
really came out of this
research was thinking about the
time of day and how people
use their devices
through the day.
And the main key takeaway
underlying all of this was
really just people are
incredibly busy.
They've got these
furious lives.
They're picking up kids.
They're working, doing all this
stuff, and it's really
important to fit into
their schedule.
So when we listen to our users,
we hear, especially
with the phone, that I need
to be in control.
I want to decide when I
come in and go out.
I don't want to be distracted
too much.
So we need to get out of their
way at the right moment.
And ideally, they really want
us to get us to where they
want to be without them
having to ask.
Obviously, the less
interaction they
can get, the better.
So when we think about what
they're doing went through the
day, a pattern that emerges as
successful is sort of punchy,
short news content
in the morning.
People are quite ritualistic
about checking in and finding
out what's going on at the
beginning of the day.
And then easygoing, pushed at
you entertaining content in
the evening, when perhaps you
want to switch off a bit more
and you don't want to be
constantly making choices.
So that tracks by
device as well.
So the phone, you tend to see
these sort of short, frequent
status-snacking behavior.
And UIs that work well with
that tend to be these more
feed-like UIs, where I can
check in, find out
what's going on.
I want a sense of what's
going on in the world.
Whereas on TV, something more
static and relaxing, less
about scrolling, more about
what's the content that I want
to be watching next
and you tell me.
So a third aspect that helps us
when we're trying to think
about designing these different
UIs is thinking
about the level of control and
trust that people need to have
over an interface.
So there are two sort
of modalities of
behavior that we see--
the "I know what I want" versus
the "Entertain me." We
notice that they
call for really
two separate UI paradigms.
One end of this continuum we're
thinking of as like
trust based and one
control based.
And if we think about a user's
intent along this continuum,
it helps us to design a feature,
a and what to watch
next after you've watched one
video on TV is an interesting
example of this.
On TV, we have the added
challenge that we've got these
very limited control input
devices, the D-pad controls.
And combine that with this
idea that we're trying to
optimize for these long,
relaxing evening sessions, and
we really find that the last
thing you want is to kind of
bombard people with these
horrific walls
of choices of videos.
So it works quite well on the
PC or on the desktop, where
you give people lots of choices,
and they can see what
it is they're after.
On the TV, you show somebody a
wall of videos like this, and
they'll just turn it off.
As somebody pointed out, it's
sort of like asking a kid,
what vegetables do you
want for dinner?
And they'll just be like,
nothing, or chips.
They'll jump back to what
they're familiar with.
Whereas you might be better
off asking them something
like, do you want broccoli
or carrots?
And then you kind of
more likely to
get a useful reaction.
And it's kind of the same with
video consumption as well.
We find if you give them a big
bombardment of choice, they
tend to react badly.
You give them a small number
of choices, then people are
much more positive about
taking one of them.
So what we try to say with these
kind of interfaces is
here's what we think you
want to watch next.
You might also like--
So we still give some
opportunity for serendipity
and a little bit of control,
like letting people go, but
we're really concentrating
on trust.
And we're experimenting with
different ideas and different
UIs, title cards that might
allow more sort of insight
into the set of videos that
you're watching such that we
gain sort of extra trust at
the beginning of the talk,
that you can really have more
faith that the videos that are
coming up are the kind of videos
that you're going to
want to be watching, rather than
giving the people this
feeling that I'm just
lost in the sea of
thousands of videos.
That way, I can lean back
and enjoy the content.
The opposite end of the scale
to this might be when people
really want control.
And as I said before, an
interface that's really great
for this is the phone.
And so, we're really looking
at ways that we can combine
these experiences.
So you might already see, we've
already got a UI that
allows you to connect the phone
YouTube experience to
your TV or to any other
large screen and let
you pair the two.
So you can send a video
from one to the other.
And these are incredibly
successful at achieving this
kind of high control.
How do I get to the video I
want, and then how do I share
it with people?
And the reaction's incredible.
If they can find it,
people describe the
experience as magical.
Especially if you've ever tried
to input a text search
through using a D-pad control,
you'll just know that these
kind of interfaces are
light years apart.
And the final piece that's
helping us coming out of this
and various other research is
the emotional connection.
So I mentioned earlier how some
of the more traditional
frameworks for thinking about
who your users are and what
they want out of your products
are not working or don't work
so well when you're user
base grows beyond
the hundreds of millions.
So we're really having to find
new ways of trying to
empathize with people.
And again, the research team
have come up with some pretty
innovative thinking
around this.
And so rather than thinking
about the personas and the
type of people coming to
YouTube, they're pushing us to
think about people's
motivations
behind why they're coming.
And they're putting together
a framework that presents
content in such a way that it
can fit to people's moods.
And we see this as making it
more likely for them to engage
with the content in
a positive way.
So an example I'm sort of giving
here of a framework we
might be trying to feel out is
under "feeling," we think
about people seeking a mood,
following a story.
I'll give some examples
of that.
And then "learning," I guess,
is more obvious.
We've got a lot of educational
content, but we also see a lot
of how-to videos and
reviews on YouTube.
And that's very important,
popular content.
"Knowing." We were talking about
people sort of being in
the know and finding out
what's new and popular.
A lot of people come and they
want to see the latest videos.
So how do we accommodate
those?
What's the right UI for somebody
coming in in that
kind of frame of mind?
And then "connecting" is
comments and discussions, but
also sharing with friends,
how we take
those experiences back.
And that hopefully connects
people back to the top of the
circle, where you can connect
with your friends and share a
feeling with them, and then
they can learn and share.
And that kind of framework, it
helps us build our use cases
and think about what success is
for a product and what we
should expect people
to get out of it.
An example of where
you might apply it
could be through language.
So "make me laugh" could well
be a phrase that is more
likely to trigger a positive
reaction to the kind of
content people want to connect
with than, say, "pets and
animals," which is the more
logical place you might want
to go to look for cat videos.
But people don't really come in
looking for cat videos and
then think, oh, I'll click on
"pets and animals." But if you
say "make me laugh," they can
kind of relate to that.
So with that, I'll hand it back
to Josh, who's going to
explain a little bit about how
you can apply these kind of
lessons to design.
JOSH SASSOON: So as Tom
mentioned, we do a ton of
qualitative research to
address a lot of our
challenges.
And what we need to do in
combination with that is use
data and quantitative analysis
to really kind of finish the
entire design process and make
sure that we're thinking about
this in a well-rounded manner.
So we think a lot about how can
database design actually
help us with our design
decisions when we're trying to
organize and present
videos to viewers.
And we use a lot of analysis to
try and figure out how can
we go from something that feels
messy to something that
feels very intentional and
something that feels organized.
And within something that feels
organized, how much
hierarchy do we show?
How much density or how
much diversity of
content do we show?
And a lot of our analysis on
the quantitative side can
really help us with that.
We have tons and tons of ideas
as we do design explorations.
But as Tom said, at the scale of
our user base, it's really
hard to just go with your
gut and say, this
is going to be great.
Because that doesn't really work
for the entire world or
for hundreds of millions
of people.
So we really need to use
data to validate
a lot of our ideas.
And this is just an exploration
where we use
quantitative analysis to think
about, how big is a thumbnail?
How often do we group and
cluster thumbnails together?
How can we actually balance
density and diversity?
How can we show through one
UI across platforms a nice
balance of universal and
personal content together and
make it feel easy to
understand and not
overwhelming, depending on
what device you're using?
This is an exploration where
we're really thinking just
about tons and tons
of diversity.
Just show a lot of stuff, and
hopefully people will make a
good decision.
But then, we'll do another
exploration that's similar but
much more minimal and
much less dense.
And we can run these two
things together as an
experiment, and through
quantitative analysis, we can
really make better decisions
about what really does work
better and what leads our
viewers to longer, more
successful sessions
on our product.
And this is an exploration,
actually, where we're
thinking, how can quantitative
analysis help us determine
what layout to use?
Should there be any hierarchy?
And in the case of this, this
is a very dense exploration
that feels very newsy and
has a masonry layout.
And how much hierarchy should
we expose at all?
How much does this actually
impact our viewers' perception
of YouTube as a destination that
they need to come back to
often as a news source or as a
newsfeed versus something that
feels very editorial and curated
and is much less
dense, and perhaps only shows
one to two pieces of content
above the fold?
And we have to think about all
of these explorations in the
spectrum, and on top of all
that, think about them across
platforms and think, how does
this actually translate and
become recognizable when you
take that same design and you
throw it onto a tablet or you
throw it onto a phone?
And what does that
actually mean?
A lot of the stuff that Tom
spoke about earlier--
the need for more control or
perhaps more personal snacking
on a phone--
is very different on a phone
than on desktop, where you
want a ton of options and
perhaps a lot more diversity
and even a sense of more
hierarchy to help you quickly
identify a type of content
you want to watch.
This is another interesting
place that we use quantitative
analysis, which is actually
analyzing our channel creators
and their content and figuring
out what type of content they
actually have and how we can
group it together and make it
more meaningful and how we can
present what they want to
watch next from a channel--
whether it's episodic content
that's meant to be viewed
sequentially or whether it's
music content or whether it's
from a large library of videos
that don't actually need to be
viewed in a certain order.
We've got tons and tons of
creators that are making
amazing new types of content
that don't fall into the
traditional, sequential sort
of show or movie sort of
content types.
So we have to really work hard
to analyze and understand what
our creators are doing and then
find the best ways to
actually present that and
cluster it to show viewers and
subscribers on our
browse pages.
So that kind of takes us to some
of the explorations that
we're taking from all of these
insights and actually moving
closer to a little bit of a
sneak peek into how we're
trying to solve the problems
we've just been discussing.
And some of it is just
really obvious--
identifying primary user needs
and actually streamlining them
visually across platforms and
doing things that actually
connect our core actions in
a unified visual language.
Something as simple as taking
our subscribe button and
making sure that it scales and
is recognizable across
platforms actually does a huge
amount to help our viewers
recognize and understand that
when they subscribe to
something, that actually
means something.
And when they pick up their
phone after they subscribe on
desktop, that that same channel
and that content will
be there, or that they'll
be able to refind it
later on their TV.
And that, again, we're a
service, and not just a site
that has a bunch of disparate
apps connected with it.
Some of the other work that
we're doing is just doing some
basic unification, both visually
and in our UI, of our
navigation.
Getting our viewers to
understand every time you open
up YouTube on any platform
that that navigation will
actually get you back
consistently to the place that
you recognize, whether it's
the What to Watch feed or
whether it's a specific
channel.
And that kind of takes us into
this bigger picture that we're
thinking of for YouTube and a
lot of the design principles
we've already mentioned.
But thinking about YouTube as
this single service that
transcends or goes across any
platform, that's easy.
It has this basic underlying
structure that you can
understand, that helps balance
the universal and the personal
and makes the experience at any
time of day, any type of
user, any type of content
understandable.
And then balance that with
what YouTube is kind of
culturally known for, which is
a serendipitous, fun kind of
silly place, a place for
adventure and delight.
A place for potentially
education and news, but also a
place that is just as much a
library for everything that
you love in the world
in video, as well
as a place for fun.
TOM BROXTON: So to bring all of
that together, I guess what
we're trying to do is strive for
recognizability but not be
dogmatic about the consistency
for the sake of consistency.
We still want each platform
to take advantage of its
strengths s so that we can
get to a future that's
recognizably a consistent family
of products living off
this one service in the center
that's optimized for the
strengths and opportunities of
each, and really give people
the right content for the right
device at the right time
of day, lets them get in and get
out when they need to, and
remembers where they are
when they come back.
JOSH SASSOON: That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM BROXTON: So we even left
a little bit of time for
questions if anybody has any.
And if not, there is a
page for feedback.
So if you want to give feedback,
you can scan the QR
code, or I think you can get
to it through the site.
And it's all gratefully
received.
Thank you.
JOSH SASSOON: Thank
you for coming.
AUDIENCE: Just one question
about the options you
presented earlier, the variants
of the teasers you
put on the YouTube main page.
What's your criteria to say
if it's successful?
Is it just click-through rate?
Is it how long the user stays
after he clicks one video?
What's the main goal on this
first on the start?
TOM BROXTON: Do you
want me to start?
JOSH SASSOON: Sure.
TOM BROXTON: It varies from
exploration for exploration.
I mean, both of those
two things are very
interesting to us.
The immediate click-through
rate, the effect that changing
something on the site has, is
definitely interesting.
But also, of course, the longer
term, like does it lead
to longer number of clicks?
What are the kind of videos
that it leads to viewing?
How does that affect the
relationship of the viewer
with the creator of the
video behind it?
So I'd say that it's difficult
to think of one common thing.
But the common principle would
be to make sure that we
understand those in advance of
running the experiment, right?
It's far too easy to run an
experiment and then look at a
bunch of numbers and to try
and pick out the winner
afterwards.
JOSH SASSOON: I mean right now,
it's really hard to come
up with a good success metric,
because we're looking for
longer-term behavioral change.
We want people to come to the
Home page and make a better
decision instead of just
watching something and
abandoning it right away or
watching something that may
lead to some other series
of random watches.
We'd rather people get really
invested and understand what
they're watching and, depending
on the context,
watch it longer if they're in a
place like on a device where
there is the potential
to watch it longer.
Or at least have a high-quality
session where
they make it through the video
and they make a good decision.
AUDIENCE: A question about the
dual-screen experience.
We haven't seen that.
How did you guys think about
basically designing a
dual-screen experience where
you use a tablet to control
what you see on a TV?
TOM BROXTON: I lost the end
of your question there.
As we've designed a dual-screen
experience--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you go after
designing it?
TOM BROXTON: Yeah, OK.
I think a lot of our initial
impulse is driven out of the
frustration we see
with search.
So if you look at our TV
experiences, you'll see the
dual-screen experience promoted
a lot from there,
because that's where we see
the biggest advantage for
people when they're having
frustration typing in controls.
So that's one of the places
where we started.
And then, the other part of
where it came from was really
thinking about, as I say, all
of the products working
together off a common service.
So rather than trying to build
specific remote control apps,
as we'd seen other people do, we
were trying to think about
well, I really should be able
to search for my content
anywhere and play it anywhere.
So that was one of the
underlying principles of the
UI we were trying to develop.
And not develop new apps, but
think about, OK, we've already
got a mobile phone app.
And we've already
got a TV app.
What's the best way of
connecting these two together,
and how do I really want to
use these two things?
There's a sort of famous use
case for YouTube, right, that
we all know about where
everybody's got a video that
they want to show everybody.
And so everybody's waiting to
queue up and play their
favorite video, so that was sort
of one of the underlying
motivations was how do we
make that really easy.
So if we can all find that video
on our phone and play it
on the TV, that's a great win.
I'd say the difficulty is
balancing all of the different
use cases together that don't
always interact, the way that
use case works next to, oh, I've
just got a playlist that
I want to put up on the TV and
leave running during a party.
The two can be kind of in
conflict with each other.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to ask,
when you're designing for
cross device, are you having
any of those devices drive
what the rest of the devices
are looking like?
Are you starting from the
phone and bringing it to
tablet elsewhere?
And then, do you feel like
you're compromising on some of
these devices because you're
trying to maintain
consistency?
Like, is this truly the best
tablet experience, or is it
the best that you can
do with consistency?
JOSH SASSOON: I mean, I came
from designing for desktop for
almost two years.
And so it's really easy to
fall into this pattern of
every feature exists on desktop,
so we're just going
to try and wedge it into mobile
or figure out how does
that work on TV.
And the reality is we just
make really concerted
decisions to constrain and say,
we just don't need to do
half of these things for
certain devices.
So we've really started to
reapproach some of our new
projects, from thinking
about, how does
this start with mobile?
How does it start
on the tablet?
How does it start on the TV?
And we're really starting to
think about desktop as an
equal instead of the first
thing we think about.
And so it's actually a pretty
interesting time for us right
now, because we're doing
all these explorations.
And granted, many of them
do start with desktop.
We're actually making sure that
we put mobile or tablet
on an equal playing field in
those explorations and say,
what do you actually really need
when you're staring at
your phone?
And 99% of the time, all the
things that we do on desktop
don't translate exactly or even
necessarily need to be there.
So again, as Tom said, we
think about familiarity.
We're not trying to just make
it absolutely consistent.
We just want to make sure that
when you're looking at your
phone and your desktop,
you feel like
you're using YouTube.
But the thing that you really
need from the phone is very
different from what you need
on the desktop experience.
TOM BROXTON: I'd say just to add
to that that's definitely
part of the motivation that
was driving a lot of the
qualitative research that
we talked about.
Because I think it's
so easy to have an
assumption of knowledge.
We have so many learned patterns
from so many years of
building a very large website
that we wanted to really
immerse ourselves in the ways
of thinking of people using
other devices.
So that was part of the driver
behind that project.
AUDIENCE: So if you were going
to add a new capability into
the YouTube service, where
would you start?
Would you look across and say,
OK, I'm trying to design
simultaneously across
all of them?
Or do you have one where you
would start and then try to
loop it back around?
JOSH SASSOON: Some of the new
features, we're thinking right
away about how does it work
across platforms.
I mean, it's kind of
overwhelming, because we're
trying to do it all.
And we'll see how that works.
But I think a lot of the
explorations now start with
mobile, mobile and desktop.
And then, TV is kind of the
next thing we think about.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
touch on some of the user
research that you guys has been
doing around kind of how
people watch TV on a large,
10-foot experience.
Do you see the need to have
TV kind of be this like
painkiller/zoning out use case
dwindling with kind of
co-viewing applications and all
the research that shows
that people are just spending
increasingly large amount of
time actually doing stuff while
they're watching TV,
whether it's just being
on Facebook on
their phone or Twitter?
It just feels like less of a
relaxing use case, and I'm
just curious how that might
change your perception of what
it's about in that 10-foot
experience and how that
changes the UI.
TOM BROXTON: I agree.
And yeah, we're definitely
seeing this same pattern.
At the same time, the latest
research we're doing just
seems to suggest the TV's
on more and in a
more passive role.
The more it's used, at the same
time, the more we see the
two things going on together,
the less interactive and the
more background role the
TV seems to gain.
Yeah.
But then, I think that the
rise of these dual-screen
applications may change
that a lot.
I think they've got
a long way to go.
I was at CES earlier this year,
and just everybody's
throwing out these sort
of dual-screen apps.
And I think there's going to be
a kind of madness of them
for a while.
And so how that affects what's
appearing on the main screen
while we all play with our
iPods is interesting.
But I can't predict the pattern
yet of how that's
going to evolve.
And I think we're running out of
time, so that might have to
be the last question.
Thank you all very
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]